we are continuing our breaking news
coverage here jeff german reportedly
extensive on the ongoings at the clark
county public administrator's office
calling its current office holder
embattled a number of articles written
rob tullis would go on ultimately to
lose the primary race which took place
in june 8 news now investigator david
charns here to show us how tullis
responded to garmin's claims yeah brian
denise we can now tell you that our
sources have been telling us that a rob
telus would likely be charged with
murder in this case we didn't want to
jeopardize the investigation as that was
going on but sources were telling us
later this afternoon basically in the
past two hours that we've been watching
this that he was going to be arrested in
connection
with jeff german's murder now i want to
talk about exactly what the public
administrator's office is these are the
people who handle a deceased person's
property if the county can't find any of
their family members they also
administer the estate if a family can't
do this in their leader rob tullis was
elected in 2017. this is an elected
position earlier this year jeff gehrman
wrote a series of articles critical of
telus that telus had said led to his
primary defeat
hello
i'm rob telles and i'm your clark county
public administrator rob tellis lays out
his county job in this campaign video
posted in march telus would end up
losing the three-way democratic primary
in june following review journal
investigative journalist jeff gearman's
reporting on his office gearman put the
loss this way in a june 19th article
telus's lagging numbers follow a review
journal investigation last month that
uncovered an office in turmoil amid
claims of bullying and retaliation and
an alleged inappropriate relationship
between telus and a staffer
unfortunately found that there were
cases that weren't being closed and
hadn't been closed for years a source
with knowledge of the office says telus
management style clashed with older
staff the person telling the
investigators some employees filed
complaints with the county about
unworkable conditions in may german
reported the county brought in the
former coroner to quote tackle friction
inside the office his article saying
co-workers accused telus of carrying on
an inappropriate relationship with the
staffer including secretly videotaping
telus in the back seat of the staffer's
car telus denied the allegation blaming
the office issues on quote a handful of
old timers i'm very happy to say that
we've turned that all around under my
leadership but it was clear from online
posts telus was not happy with german's
reporting he writes in one post german
was dragging him through the mud writing
on his campaign site the articles were
false and benefited one of his primary
opponents telus also wrote german this
letter in june saying he wouldn't let
the allegations affect his work
and we're just learning that metro will
be holding a news conference tomorrow
with sheriff joe lombardo at ten o'clock
eight news now will be carrying that
online and on air when that happens
again tell us arrested just a few
moments ago we have asked the county
about his employment status today that
was before his arrest we have not heard
back but again this is an elected
position and that sort of changes things
when it comes to employment status we'll
let you know as soon as we know i'm
david charns 8 news now